may 5th before you watch this video may
5th i'm dropping it
huge project please please pay attention
to all my socials all my channels may
5th i've got a secret project i'm
dropping it with a complete focus
on making sure a that everybody's part
of this community my
og social media content youtube gets to
really win
wait do you see the way i structured
this this isn't just the art there's a
lot of access and community
and a lot of [ __ ] thoughtfulness
months and months in the making may 5th
be ready
have your metamask filled with as much
ethereum as you can afford
we're doing it gary
garyvee showed me
millennials it's me garyvee i am
ridiculously humbled
by having this quick opportunity to say
what's up
what's good how are you for those of you
that don't know me
i'm gary vaynerchuk i'm an entrepreneur
uh i'm a new york jets fan
i'm a jersey boy that was born in the
soviet union that uh
is very grateful and driven by
perspective around
patience optimism practicality
work ethic kindness and what's really
exciting for me is hey
first of all kudos to everybody who's
watching this to finding this place
i love the innovation of the internet
and facebook groups i think has been
remarkable for many different people
uh and and knowing that there's a large
group of millennials in here
who are feeding off each other helping
each other really makes my heart smile
i have very little time so let me just
get right to the chase
life is about perspective at 23 24 25 26
27 28 years old i
was stocking shelves and ringing up
people
for wine purchases at
there we go wine purchases at a liquor
store
most people in their early 20s greatest
mistake
is not understanding how young there
they are as a matter of fact
as all of you are looking for jobs or
figuring out a post-coveted world or
sad that you missed graduation or spring
break the reality is
you have a hundred years of life in
front of you
you haven't even started having it
figured out by 25
27 30 is ridiculous the anxiety that
people feel at 30 as a matter of fact it
is literally drock's
30th birthday today and
he's never felt younger because he's
been in a cocoon
of my world for the last half decade
right you've never felt younger
right and these characters are 22 23 19
20 you haven't even started i don't want
to hear that you can't get a job enjoy
your vacation
enjoy your vacation and by the way you
have no money and you can't enjoy
get six roommates like you're a kid
do not listen to your parents or society
that you have to have it figured out
it's just not true
most your parents have not had it
figured out ever let alone at 22
23 take a breath be grateful that you're
alive and are watching this video
gratitude of what you have
versus crying about what you don't have
most of you are stressed about getting a
job and then you're gonna have a job in
six months
and you're not even gonna like it take a
breath
i gave up all my 20s to build a big wine
store for my dad and mom
i spent my 20s into my early 30s getting
underpaid for what i was doing for their
business
because it's a family business to set
them up proper
and then at 34 kind of started the
career that you know me for now
think about that 34
34 that's a hundred years away
millennials
you are sitting in the best spot you are
in the most fortunate spot nfts
social media influencers shopify
commerce spotify soundcloud
creativity everywhere people needing
people that understand social
everywhere people needing people filming
and recording and editing and writing
everywhere entrepreneurship opportunity
everywhere and if you do everything
wrong
for the next seven eight nine years
everything wrong
you're still then young to go
conservative or
safe or back to school or
stop people's relationship with time
is their greatest vulnerability and my
great hope is in these five minutes
i've changed the framework or started
the spark
or the seed for you to get much more
thoughtful
about the reality of you and your age
and where you are in your life cycle
this doesn't mean be lazy and chill on
the couch have ambition
and conviction but have patience and
humility
you worrying about what everybody else
thinks of your success
is your vulnerability put these fingers
in your ears live for you
be high risk now because it's actually
practical
i'm so honored to be here i hope this
brought you a second
of value please dm me dm me garyvee on
instagram
hit me up on my gary facebook page
whatever works for you
i'm here for you if i can i get flooded
but i still randomly do it
i'm here let me help i hope you have a
great day thank you for having me really
really thank you so much for having me
and keep
curious keep patient
and keep conviction for doing it for you
even though you love and respect other
people's opinions
you have to do it for you thank you
youtube watcher what's up it's garyvee
first of all thank you so much i hope
you're doing super well during these
times i also want to ask you please
subscribe because my
commitment and exploration of youtube is
about to explode stories polls
more content more engagement more
surprise and delight
this is the time to subscribe i hope you
consider it and i hope i see you soon
you